ça on va pas les faire voir je suis sûr
qu'il y avait beaucoup de curieux qui
aimeraient les voir mais non cet étage
là n'est pas ouvert au public uniquement
le premier étage et le rez-de-chaussée
comme d'habitude
là ça reste vraiment un réparer vous le
voyez si les appartements du second
étage restent fermés pour l'instant tout
le reste du château se prépare à renouer
avec les visiteurs
ces autorisations il y a pas si
longtemps que ça c'était il y a quelques
semaines donc jusque là on était pas sûr
à 100% on espérait donc on faisait
exactement comme si on allait ouvrir on
n'avait pas le choix fallait commencer à
tout mettre en place à faire les
commandes à mettre en place la boutique
les transats etc mais voilà on était un
peu en panique de se dire que peut-être
ça ne se ferait pas et au final
on va pouvoir ouvrir donc c'est la
meilleure nouvelle qu'on pouvait avoir
cette année je crois après des mois
d'expertise de certification et de
démarches administratives le château de
l'illette ouvre sa saison 2023 avec ses
animations estivales les travaux liés à
la restauration du plancher s'accompagne
même d'un nouveau projet
la première
chose c'est que il y avait des
fragilités qui maintenant sont détectés
et ça c'est quand même important la
deuxième c'est que depuis longtemps on
imaginait
c'était un projet un peu évanescent de
dire tiens ce serait bien si on pouvait
ouvrir les combles au public là on peut
vraiment tenter de mener ce projet à
terme en espérant peut-être que pour la
saison prochaine c'est à dire dans un an
nos visiteurs découvrent cette belle
charpente au château de une mauvaise
réparation 19e se transforme en force de
l'architecture Renaissance